>> Tucker: WELL, IF YOU LOOK
CAREFULLY, YOU'LL SEE SUBTLE
SIGNS OF DECAY THROUGHOUT OUR
SOCIETY.
STARBUCKS, ONE EXAMPLE, RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED GOING FORWARD ITS
SEATS AND BATHROOMS WILL BE
OPENED TO NONPAYING CUSTOMERS.
THAT'S BAD NEWS IF YOU WANT TO
BRING YOUR KIDS THERE.
PRETTY GOOD NEWS IF YOU'RE A
VAGRANT.
MEANWHILE IN NEW YORK A COUPLE
HAD TO EVICT THEIR 30-YEAR-OLD
SON FROM THEIR BASEMENT BECAUSE
HE REFUSED TO MOVE OUT.
MANY DEFENDED HIS DECISION TO
LIVE THERE FOREVER.
MIKE IS THE HOST OF THE TBN SHOW
"SOMEBODY'S GOT TO DO IT."
LATEST SEASON OF THAT WILL DEBUT
SOON.
HE SPOKE TO US ABOUT THESE
STORIES AND HOW THEY MAY BE
CONNECTED.
HERE IT IS.
>> JOINING US TONIGHT IS MIKE
ROWE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, MIKE.
>> TUCKER, THANK YOU.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> Tucker: CAN'T BE BETTER?
STARBUCKS ANNOUNCING YOU NO
LONGER HAVE TO BUY ANYTHING TO
LOUNGE AROUND ITS STORES OR USE
THE BATHROOM.
MEANWHILE, 30-YEAR-OLDS ARE
SUING TO STAY IN THEIR PARENTS'
BASEMENTS.
ARE THESE STORIES CONNECTED?
DO THEY TELL US SOMETHING BIGGER
ABOUT WHERE THE COUNTRY IS
GOING?
>> DOGS AND CATS LIVING
TOGETHER!
MASS HYSTERIA.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
>> LOOK, I PERSONALLY, I'M IN
THE MIDST RIGHT NOW OF DOING
WHAT I DO EVERY YEAR WHICH IS
TRY AND GIVE AWAY WORK ETHIC
SCHOLARSHIPS.
IT GETS HARDER EVERY YEAR, SO,
UM --
>> Tucker: WAIT, WAIT IT GETS
HARDER TO GIVE AWAY MONEY?
>> WE'VE GIVEN AWAY $5 MILLION
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS, AND,
YES, EVERY YEAR, IT GETS
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO
AFFIRMATIVELY REWARD WORK ETHIC.
THERE'S SOME THINGS MY
SCHOLARSHIP REQUIRES YOU TO DO
THAT OTHER SCHOLARSHIPS DON'T.
YOU HAVE TO WRITE ESSAYS AND
MAKE VIDEOS SIGN A SWEAT PLEDGE.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE OFTEN CONFRONTED
THROUGH THESE HOOPS IN WHICH I
ASK THEM TO LEAP, THEY TAKE
UMBRIDGE AT THAT.
I FIND IT FASCINATING.
IT DOESN'T BOTHER ME SO MUCH
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THAT A
VALUABLE THING IS ALMOST ALWAYS
A THING THAT IS IN DEMAND AND
WORK ETHIC IS VERY MUCH IN
DEMAND, BUT TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION, WHY IS IT HARDER TO
FIND IT?
I THINK THAT PROBABLY DOES HAVE
SOMETHING TO DO WITH THE
EXPECTATIONS THAT HAVE EVOLVED
OUT OF THE SAFE SPACE MOVEMENT
WHICH YOU'VE DONE A LOT TO TALK
ABOUT ON YOUR PROGRAM, AND I'M
STARTING TO THINK THAT MAYBE
THERE IS A LINK BETWEEN THE
EXPECTATIONS A PATRON MIGHT HAVE
AT A STARBUCKS VIS-A-VIS THE
EXPECTATIONS A SQUATTER WHO JUST
HAPPENS TO BE GENETICALLY TIED
TO YOU MIGHT HAVE VIS-A-VIS THE
BASEMENT IN WHICH HE CURRENTLY
DWELLS, ETC., ETC.
YOU KNOW, I MEAN, OF ALL THE
DIVIDES IN THE COUNTRY, I THINK
YOU COULD PROBABLY MAKE A PRETTY
INTERESTING CASE THAT THERE'S A
FISSURE RUNNING THROUGH THE
EXPECTATION OF WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
WE ELEVATE SAFETY AND FEELINGS
TO A LEVEL OF PRIMACY.
I THINK IT CREATES A REAL
DISCONNECT THAT PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING TO PARSE.
>> Tucker: WAIT A SECOND!
ARE YOU SAYING SAFETY ISN'T THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING EVER?
>> I'M SAYING THAT EVERYBODY
WANTS TO GO HOME SAFE AT THE END
OF THE DAY.
SAFETY ALWAYS WOULD BE A
DELIGHTFUL BROMIDE A DELIGHTFUL
FLATTUDE.
SAFETY FIRST IS THE STUFF OF
IDIOCY.
IT ALLOWS US TO BEGIN TO BELIEVE
THAT SOMEONE OTHER THAN US MIGHT
CARE MORE ABOUT OUR WELL-BEING
THAN WE DO, AND THE MINUTE WE
BUY INTO THAT NONSENSE, THEN WE
EMBRACE THE WARM GRIP OF
COMPLACENCY.
SO, NO, SAFETY IS NOT THE ENEMY,
BUT IF YOU MAKE IT THE PRIORITY,
THEN LET'S JUST WRAP OURSELVES
IN BUBBLE PACK AND DRIVE AT
SPEEDS APPROACHING 5 MILES PER
HOUR AND NEVER ASSUME ANYTHING
THAT COULD EVER BE CONFUSED WITH
RISK.
>> Tucker: THAT IS REALLY
DEEP!
WHEN YOU SAY SAFETY FIRST,
YOU'RE ASSUMING -- NO -- I'M
SERIOUS.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MANY
UNARTICULATED ASSUMPTIONS THAT
GOVERNOR OUR SOCIETY AND NO ONE
EVER EXAMINES THEM IN THE LIGHT
OF DAY.
YOU JUST DID.
WHEN YOU SAY SAFETY FIRST, AURE
SUMMING SOMEONE OUT THERE CARES
MORE ABOUT YOUR WELL-BEING THAN
YOU -- YOU ASSUME THAT SOMEONE
OUT THERE CARES MORE ABOUT YOUR
WELL-BEING THAN YOU DO?
>> YEAH, ON "DIRTY JOBS" MY CREW
AND I SAT THROUGH OVER 100
MANDATORY BRIEFINGS.
THROUGH THE FIRST COUPLE OF
SEASONS, THEY WERE VERY
EFFECTIVE, BECAUSE WE LISTENED
LIKE THIS.
WE WERE VERY CONCERNED.
WE WERE IN A DANGEROUS, HOSTILE,
UNKNOWN ENVIRONMENT.
BUT OVER TIME, THE BIG SAFETY
FIRST PLAQARTS AND THE MANDATORY
BOXES YOU HAVE TO CHECK AND THE
LOCK IN AND LOCK OUT PROCEDURES,
THOSE THINGS TURN INTO THE
TEACHER IN CHARLIE BROWN.
WAH-WAH-WAH.
YOU STOP LISTENING.
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
TELLING YOU NOTHING IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN YOUR SAFETY IS
THE VERY DYNAMIC THAT HAS PEOPLE
WALK ACROSS FIFTH AVENUE WHEN
THE LITTLE MAN SAYS WALK INSTEAD
OF LOOKING BOTH WAYS.
IT'S NOT A COINCIDENCE THE MOST
DANGEROUS INTERSECTIONS IN THE
WORLD ARE INTERSECTION THAT HAS
HAVE SIGNS TO TELL WHEN YOU TO
WALK.
AGAIN, WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
WITH THE MINIMUM WAGE, WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT IT WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS BUT THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
MAGNIFYING A VIRTUE TO A PLACE
IT DOESN'T DESERVE TO OCCUPY
WILL ALWAYS COME BACK TO KICK US
IN THE THROAT.
>> Tucker: REALLY DEEP.
SO ARE THERE SAFETY BRIEFINGS ON
YOUR NEWS SHOW?
YOU HAVE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
DIGITAL SHOWS THAT'S EVER BEEN.
HOW MUCH SAFETY IS IN THAT SHOW?
>> WELL, SAFETY, LIKE I SAID, IS
ALWAYS PRESENT IN EVERYTHING
I'VE DONE.
DIRTNY JOBS, SOMEBODY OTHERS
THAT DO IT.
RETURNING THE FAVOR.
WE ALWAYS FOCUS ON GOING HOME IN
ONE PIECE, BUT PART OF DOING
THAT IN MY WORLD IS TO SAY
SAFETY THIRD.
NOW, THAT'S CONTROVERSIAL.
THAT MAKES PEOPLE GO, WHAT ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT?
WHAT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAN
SAFETY?
NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU'RE
HAVING A CONVERSATION ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT WILL ULTIMATELY
REDOWNED TO PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
SAFETY THIRD IS JUST A WAY OF
CUTTING THROUGH THE WARM MILK
AND THE SOFT TISSUE THAT MAKES
EVERYBODY COMFORTABLE WHEN I SAY
EVERYBODY, I MEAN ACTUARIAL
ACCOUNTANTS, HAD C AND INSURANCE
ADJUSTERS.
YOU'VE DONE IT.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU GONE ON
A PLANE AND BEEN TOLD BY THE
PILOTS THAT THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS TO GET YOU HOME IN ONE
PIECE.
JUST ONCE I'D LIKE THE PILOT TO
SAY, LOOK, SIT BACK AND RELAX
BECAUSE I LOVE MY WIFE, KIDS AND
DAUGHTERS, I WANT TO GET HOME IN
ONE PIECE.
STRAP YOURSELF IN AND ENJOY THE
RIDE.
YOU'VE NEVER BEEN IN BETTER
HANDS, ADD YO.
>> Tucker: -- ADIOS.
>> Tucker: WHEN THE PLANE GOES
DOWN, PRAYER IS ALL YOU'VE GOT.